décris en guise d'appel à l'aide
ce sont ceux d'une femme coincée sous
les gravats
quelques minutes plus tard elle en sort
finalement saine et sauve grâce au
travail acharné de cette équipe de
sauveteurs
en prenant de la hauteur on découvre un
cratère immense
île témoigne de la violence de la frappe
cette nuit un missile russe s'est abattu
ici à cramatorze les habitants ont été
surpris pendant leur sommeil
je dormais avec ma fille et on a été
réveillé parce que le plafond nous est
tombé dessus
mon enfant a 8 ans et elle me disait je
ne peux pas sortir
elle criait
on a été découvert de verts et de débris
de fenêtres tout s'est écrasé sur nous
mon mari et moi es-tu ensemble dans la
chambre on a essayé de sortir au final
j'ai quelques égratignures et mon mari a
un traumatisme crânien
des frappes russes qui ont également
touché Odessa ville située sur les bords
de la Mer Noire elles ont fait plusieurs
victimes l'oeuvre de Moscou alors que
Kiev poursuit sa contre-offensive et
comme depuis 16 mois deux versions
radicalement différentes se font face
pour Vladimir Poutine c'est un échec les
Ukrainiens subissent des pertes jugées
catastrophiques faux selon vos leadersky
qui indique de son côté que son armée
gagne du terrain avec plusieurs
localités reprises russes ces derniers
jours notamment dans la région de
zapoidien